this is viet nam's answer to venice the
karma region crisscrossed by countless
river courses this is a city of
fishermen merchants and artists here a
musician entertains market vendors and
gets a reward every day sellers at the
stands offer a wide variety of fruits
seafood and poultry so fresh it almost
walked away
you
and right at the heart of it all is Mick
one stand
Wow half a year ago I closed my cafe on
the outskirts of the city and opened a
restaurant here in the market lots of
vendors come to me and sometimes even
tourists early in the morning she cooks
pork caramelized in sugar that makes the
pork sweet after two hours she adds hard
boiled duck eggs and more sugar tick
tock toe is what maguann calls the snack
she makes it all simmers together till
it's nice and brown after all it has to
look good as well as taste good maguann
sells a portion of tick octo for about a
year oh it's very filling okay okay oh I
think my pork dish is very popular here
I serve it with rice and pickles people
love to eat it because it's nice and
sweet and it's easy to eat Carla and I
gotta yang make one sells about 80
portions a day many Vietnamese people
eat breakfast or lunch at stands like
this the pickles give big one snackage
special taste
and how do our customers like it I like
to read it and the combination of pork
and duck eggs is unique and delicious
maguann also has a few tables for guests
who have time to sit down that's so
wonderfully sweet great the snack is
eaten with a spoon rather than
chopsticks that's unusual in Vietnam
most of our customers have to rush back
to their own stands so maguann also
sells her tick hot toe to go